I'm interested in I think everybody is
interested in the Three Laws of Robotics
could you explain those well back in
1939 I began writing robot stories and
by the time I'd written two and three
there was a pattern in these stories
which John Campbell the editor of
astounding science fiction and my
literary father pointed out to me he
said I was having my robots behave as
though they were guided by three laws
the first law was that a robot couldn't
hurt a human being or through inaction
allow a human being to come to harm the
second law was that a robot had to obey
orders given it by human beings provided
that didn't conflict with the first law
and the third law was that a robot had
to protect its own existence except
where that would conflict with the first
two laws and after that I always use
them and the stories evolve out of those
three laws out of the in the mutual
contradictions out of the ambivalences
the incongruities and so on the
interesting thing is that scientists say
that when robots are built that they may
be built according to these laws and
also that almost all science fiction
writers have adopted them as well in
their story that's true about the
science fiction writers adopting them
they are now taken for granted no writer
actually quotes them except myself but
the readers are so used to it now that
they know it and they take it for
granted and they somebody writing in an
architectural journal pointed out that
these laws hold for tools generally
number one a tool must be safe to use
and two provided it is safe to use it's
got to do what you wanted to do and
third provided it is safe to use and it
does what you want those got a list but
could your Three Laws of Robotics be
overloaded on the side of humanism there
are those who believe that the machines
we create are going to be Frankenstein's
well of course the Three Laws of
Robotics were originally invented by me
in order to avoid the Frankenstein
motive because before I wrote my stories
most robot stories were filled with this
Frankenstein bit about the robot
destroying its creator there are some
things that men were not meant to
however having worked with the three
loss for now for 35 years practically I
was asked to write a robot story to end
all robot stories so I wrote one which
robots became so intelligent that by any
reasonable definition they defined
themselves as human beings you see so
that now the three laws of robots be
robotics became the Three Laws of
humanics and we're right back to the
Frankenstein motif I received letters
from readers saying does this mean
you're never going to write any more
robust stories now I wrote back saying
don't worry if I think of a good robot
story I'll write it anyway
you